que justicia 11j verifican actualizan y
también divulgan información vinculada
con protestas públicas en Cuba esto
desde este estallido social no de que
hablamos en el año 2021 Qué información
manejan sobre la cantidad de gente que
al día de hoy permanece detenida y
también sobre las condiciones en las que
se encuentran
Sí bueno en justicia Muchas gracias por
la invitación por esta oportunidad de
contar que ha sido de la situación en
Cuba desde el 11 de julio de 2021 y
bueno en este caso nuestra organización
surgió el propio día 11 de Julio en la
noche cuando la desesperación nos llevó
como ciudadanas a documentar los casos
en ese momento eran desapariciones
forzadas de corto término porque no
sabíamos no conocíamos el paradero de
las personas que que habían manifestada
que se habían manifestado en Cuba a lo
largo de 60 localidades del país
entonces esa lista empezó a crecer y a
crecer hasta el día de hoy que manejamos
un total de mil ochocientas sesenta
detenciones a personas que se
manifestaron en el país y bueno en la
actualidad las cifras también han
variado en cuanto a los que permanecen
detenidos esta cifra quedaba
inicialmente se refiere a de desde el 11
de Julio hasta la actualidad no quiere
decir que todas esas personas Las mil
ochocientas sesentas estén detenidas al
día de hoy sino que hoy por hoy las que
contabilizamos son más de 700 en prisión
el régimen de hecho dio la la
información de que setecientas noventa
personas estaban siendo procesadas en el
país en relación con el estallido del
once j y bueno posteriormente nosotros
alcanzamos Esa esa cifra y la superamos
también una una cifra que nos guste
Resaltar Porque es importante decirlo es
que al casi 100 personas casi sin
centenar de personas han tenido que
exiliarse como resultado de estas
protestas masivas
darcy dos años después de aquellas
históricas protestas por libertad y en
contra de la crisis económica Cómo viven
hoy en la isla
bueno las protestas han persistido no
fue una cosa de un día no fue cuestión
de un día sino que a lo largo de 2021
dos mil veintidós y de hecho en lo que
va de 2023 también se han registrado
protestas en el país una reciente que
también fue de mucha connotación ocurrió
en la localidad de caimanera que está
próxima a la base naval de Estados
Unidos en guantánamo y esto forma parte
también de de la narrativa que se
intentó
imponer En aquel momento de que tenía
que ver todo con el exilio histórico
cubano en Miami intervención de Estados
Unidos cuando las protestas se generaron
desde el propio interior del país desde
una localidad como San Antonio de los
baños en que ya las personas
sinceramente no aguantaron más la
situación y se lanzaron a las calles y
hoy por hoy Yo diría que persisten las
mismas demandas que llevaron a los
cubanos a las calles en Julio de 2021
incluso puede que se hayan
acrecentado algunos problemas como el el
acceso a la salud pública también a una
vida digna y a Un entierro digno porque
muchas veces ni siquiera hay ambulancias
para trasladar a las personas
a los hospitales